[Music]
makes a lot of negative things no but
this is some good news in an effort to
eliminate nasty or pointless comments
YouTube has now made it necessary to log
in using your real name if you want to
comment on a video yeah and I think
that's great
because I've always been stunned by some
of the anonymous comments that people
make it's usually awful things no one
would ever have the guts to say in
person and by the way just for the
record yes my screen name on YouTube
although LOF is out is cone bone 69 lol
lol lol excuse me these show rocks with
12 X's rotflmao smiley face and then
another smiley face with sunglasses yeah
okay thank you sir I guess you like the
joke but please don't interrupt okay
yeah that joke was lame and that last
commenter gay I am responding in all
caps with no punctuation screw you you
homophobe okay look thank you for all
your thoughts I appreciate it the real
joke here is Obamacare anybody who
disagrees with me is just a mindless
sheep we've been brainwashed by the
liberal media shut up you Fox News
loving patches why don't you go back to
Nazi Germany this sentence is still in
all cats with no punctuation first okay
that's it just stop excuse me excuse me
yes yes what is it it's better be
important because I'd really like to
move on with the show
yes I promise this is very important
okay fine what is it my sister-in-law
makes thousands a week working at home
and you can't - HTTP colon forward slash
forward slash WWE kool-aid I've clearly
lost control here first period show
period ever period Andy what are you
doing in the audience stop being a
jackass haters gonna hate that sketch
was a comment on where we are as a
society and if we're not careful where
we're headed brought to you by the
Annenberg School of sociological meaning
and humor add Smuckers but the dad likes
[ __ ] there's no telling what you're
eating
[Applause]